nouveau numéro de reporter le dock le
magazine de reportages long format de
france 24
direction l'afrique où l'exploitation de
mines d'or artisanale est en plein essor
un phénomène qui échappent souvent aux
autorités mais pas aux groupes armés
djihadistes notamment qui contrôle de
grands territoires le mali s'impose
progressivement comme le principal
centre d'achat d'or des pays sahéliens
et dubaï est devenue ces cinq dernières
années la principale destination de la
production du continent africain mais en
fermant les yeux sur l'origine des
lingots qui arrive sur son territoire
les émirats arabes unis serait-il
indirectement complices du terrorisme
les institutions comme le cd eux
demandent en tout cas des régulations
plus strictes de bamako à dubaï en
passant par la côte d'ivoire c'est une
enquête exclusive signée caroline dumay
correspondante de france 24 en afrique
[Musique]
une nouvelle ruée vers l'or en afrique
subsaharienne
une fièvre qui attire tous les migrants
le nombre de mines d'or artisanale
illégal explose et le mali s'impose
comme le principal centre d'achat d'or
des pays sahéliens un boom aurifères qui
échappent au contrôle des états et qui
suscite la convoitise croissante des
conflits armés
on a des soudanais on a des erythréens
vous avez fait pas de juger rien de
burkinabè toutes les maturités vient ce
qui est pour nous un islam indiqué que
ces pièces ou dans les sous sols à
partir comment
une production impossible à quantifier
mais qui opèrent à ciel ouvert
[Musique]
ces pépites qui arrivent dans les
comptoirs de bamako viennent de toute
l'afrique subsaharienne
elles sont mélangées puis fondue dans
des raffineries qui fonctionne
discrètement sous des toits du grand
marché
[Musique]
l'origine de l'or est impossible à
retracer et la plupart de ces lingots
seront envoyés aux émirats arabes unis
dubin importe dès lors avec une simple
facture
factures commerciales et l'entrée du bel
déclare il paie mep dollars american
flat fille à la douane et il avoue
baryté
soucier ou le gris scandale ici ou là
bas
dubaï est devenue la principale
destination de la production d'or légal
et illégal du continent africain
les raffineries des émirats arabes unis
blanchissent leur salle des zones de
conflit
des mines illégales du sahel haut gratte
ciel de dubaï notre enquête permet de
mieux comprendre comment le secteur
aurifère mondial change de visage
[Musique]
notre enquête commence en afrique du sud
où la chasse aux exploitants illégaux
d'or et quotidienne
les unités d'élite spécialisée opère des
descentes régulières dans les mines
artisanales illégal
ils disent qu'ils ont du mal à survivre
il n'y a pas de travail c'est pour cela
qu'ils font ça
c'est un travail illégal mais très prisé
l'or est le meilleur moyen de financer
des activités criminelles
son prix augmente régulièrement il se
transporte et se revend n'importe où ils
se mélangent facilement pour les sud
africains il n'y a pas de petits trafics
nous avons ce que l'on appelle les à
manama les à manama ce sont des mineurs
illégaux c'est un mot zoulou qui veut
dire tente ta chance ou fait quelque
chose avec rien mais vous savez quand on
traite de ces choses là on n'est pas
naïf on sait bien que ce soit les à
manama où les trafiquants d'or des
niveaux plus élevés on met tout sur le
plan du grand banditisme du financement
du terrorisme parce que dans tous les
coins du monde les méthodes sont les
mêmes
buts les groupes criminels
transnationaux comme les organisations
terroristes utilisent le commerce de
l'or pour financer toutes les opérations
le général caldwell le patron des
faucons cette branche de la police sud
africaine s'est spécialisé sur le crime
organisé
l'afrique du sud fait du trafic d'or une
priorité car le pays est non seulement
producteur d'or mais il est devenu l'une
des plaques tournantes du trafic du
continent les services du général
intercepte régulièrement d'importantes
cargaisons
[Musique]
le 31 décembre 2020 un avion privé en
provenance de madagascar atterri à
johannesbourg mais en fouillant les
bagages des passagers qui devaient se
rendre à dubaï l'as douanes découvrent
plus de 73 kg d'or brut
les passagers montre aux autorités
sud-africaines des factures d'une
société baptisée sky god immatriculés au
mali l'équivalent de 3 millions d'euros
de marchandises n'ont pas été déclarés
les suspects sont immédiatement traduits
en justice ils sont de nationalité
malgache les autorités d'antananarive
demande leur extradition et réclame la
marchandise car l'exportation dort est
interdite sur la grande île depuis 2020
mais il leur faudra prouver que l'or a
effectivement été extraits à madagascar
madagascar accepte les documents du mali
confirmant l'achat de l'or cependant
madagascar affirme que sur les 73 kg
d'or 3 kg seulement ont été achetés aux
manies
les responsables de sky gold sont passés
par l'aéroport de bamako quelques mois
plus tôt mais difficile de savoir
combien de lingots ils ont effectivement
ramené du mali le dossier d'instruction
dispose de documents contradictoires
premier formulaire montre que les 73 kg
ont bien été déclaré
l'or était destiné à la société par
pierre de dubaï
mais dans un deuxième document sur
lequel figurent aussi un tampon des
douanes maliennes la société sky golden
a déclaré que trois kilogrammes d'or
brut
[Musique]
dans un monde où les fausses factures
sont monnaie courante
l' enquête de la justice sud africaine
continue
pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi
leurs saisies en afrique du sud est
passée par le mali destination bamako
dont la capitale malienne le responsable
des douanes que nous avons sollicité n'a
pas trouvé le temps de nous recevoir
alors nous nous sommes dirigés vers le
grand marché où la société sky gold
avait domicilié sa facture mais personne
ici ne connaissait cette société son
téléphone a été coupé
cette compagnie pourtant existent nous
avons retrouvé son certificat
d'immatriculation
elle a vu le jour en 2014 avec un
capital d'un million de francs cfa
modeste pour acheter pour plus de 2
milliards de francs cfa d'or
sky gold a pour adresse l'immeuble amary
daou nous y sommes il paraît d affecter
tous les immeubles de ce type au grand
marché abrite de très nombreux petits
commerces il faut se faufiler jusqu'à
laitages pour trouver des comptoirs
d'achat et de fonte de l'or
nous avons eu un accès exceptionnel à
l'un d'entre eux
fouille à l'entrée
et dramane qui travaillent ici depuis
plus de 10 ans nous fait le tour du
propriétaire
et les indiens si
[Musique]
besoin
on réceptionne et des petites pépites
qui viennent de toute la sous région ce
comptoir achète en fonction du poids et
de la qualité de l'or des carrats autour
de 50 euros le gramme une petite fortune
dans un pays où le salaire dépasse
rarement les 100 euros par mois
tous là j'aime ça comme ça même la
d'image
yale centaines de personnes qui viennent
ici un peu partout au mali mandé quoi eh
bien allez sert aussi comme le raconte
d'ivoire le burkina et villa la gaine
ici on nous assure que c'est lors du
mali qui est le plus prisé car il est
généralement de meilleure qualité que
celui des pays voisins
il ya six ans de disette aussi
l'état malien le monopole des comptoirs
d'orpaillage mais aussi de l'exportation
rien ne peut se faire ici sans le
consentement des autorités
ces fonderies installé sous les toits du
grand marché de bamako traite
essentiellement de l'or artisanale qui
représenterait aujourd'hui la moitié des
exportations du mali
une fois mélangé les pépites sont
fondues sur des réchauds de fortune
[Musique]
personne ne pourra jamais déterminées
avec précision l'origine du métal
précieux qui sera exportée dans le reste
du monde
en dépit de la crise politico-militaire
qui sévit au mali le commerce de l'or
connaît un essor remarquable
le cours de l'or a atteint des records
historiques ces deux dernières années et
ce n'est pas la guerre qui a limité la
production mais la pandémie de couronnes
à virus qui a ralenti la circulation des
hommes et des marchandises
mais les affaires ont repris ce fondeur
assure produire quotidiennement entre 80
et 100 kg de lingots ce qui représente
plus de 5 millions d'euros tous les
jours
pourquoi on oppose souvent servi à
beaucoup se voient se passait bien
la lyre importe leur situation bravo
c'est là demain pour
faux mails de vis à vis sans fin de
soirée que l'on
comprenait plus décembre qu'elle allait
bien
les lingots produits seront ensuite
numérotées en fonction de leur poids et
de la pureté de l'or qu'ils contiennent
après ma faute maintenant on en apprend
ici salut j'ai aussi
[Musique]
dans ce comptoir on affirme envoyer à
l'étranger des cargaisons tous les jours
via l'aéroport de bamako
bon
[Musique]
valentino nos cinq concerts
ça c'est santander
il y a quelques années leurs africains à
aller vers la suisse où vers l'afrique
du sud mais aujourd'hui il prend le
chemin de dubaï
les chiffres sont difficiles à vérifier
car les statistiques d'exportation des
pays africains à destination de dubaï
n'ont rien à voir avec les statistiques
d'importation des émirats arabes unis en
provenance du continent au mali par
exemple ont déclaré exportés en 2010 9
500 kg par an sur dubaï mais les émirats
arabes unis affirmait importer la même
année plus de 80 tonnes en provenance de
bamako
l'hémorragie est telle que les lingots
de sky doll destiné à dubaï ont une
grande chance de contenir de l'or du
mali légal ou illégal
[Musique]
plus de 350 sites miniers légaux sont
recensés au mali mais à la faveur de la
guerre la production artisanale illégal
a explosé
nous avons obtenues ces images
exclusives de la mine dinka a qu'à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres au sud-ouest
de gao
c'est le plus grand site d'orpaillage
dans le nord du mali
sur des dizaines de kilomètres
les pioches et l'état me soulève d'épais
nuages de poussière
battu par les vents de sable les
conditions de travail dans ces mines
sont déplorables
comme dans les autres sites artisanaux
du sahel on trouve ici de nombreuses
nationalités
sudan et nigériens libériens ghanéen
burkinabè mais aussi des libyens des
syriens
la population de cette zone est
impossible à estimer mais elles
dépasseraient celles de la ville de gao
qui abrite déjà plus de cent vingt mille
habitants
cette zone isolée échappent au contrôle
du gouvernement malien
le csp qui regroupe les principaux
mouvements armés signataires de l'accord
d'alger la coordination des mouvements
de l'azawad assurent la sécurité de ces
mineurs
mais les attaques des indices peuvent
survenir à tout moment
les mineurs qui ont accepté de répondre
à nos questions explique que la
population qui était régulièrement
attaqués aux pillés ce sont aujourd'hui
suffisamment protégé pour travailler
ce site d'orpaillage à plus de deux
voire trois ans même la sécurité semble
être assurée les gens sont en paix et en
sécurité
chacun fait de son mieux on gagne en
fonction de notre travail de notre
assiduité et de tout ce que nous
possédons que matériel pour travailler
mais tous les gens qui travaillent ici
gagne au moins deux voire quatre senti
gramme d'or par jour moi je travaille
pour moi même et je ne travaille pour
personne
les personnes qu'on fait travailler sont
rémunérés selon les compromis fixé par
les occupants du site
certains mineurs ont beaucoup de
matériel parce que les intermédiaires
avec qui il travaille fonctionne sur des
commandes d'or régulière et prépayés les
acheteurs viennent de partout des pays
des émirats mais aussi plus récemment de
turquie ou de russie
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
leaders des mouvements de l'azawad qui
contrôle la mine d'or d'inata aka près
de gao comme celle de la région de kidal
le chef de la délégation revenait d'une
grande tournée de plus de 3000 km dans
le pays il nous a expliqué que pour les
populations du nord l'exploitation
artisanale de l'or a commencé à la
faveur de la guerre et des désillusions
par rapport à la gouvernance des étapes
du sahel
les états les fonds monétaire
international la banque mondiale j'ai
pas l'eau à dallas ces derniers mois ne
vous plait ça ne parle pas
ils ont dit qu'ils les règles de jeu des
états les coups ni des impôts des
budgets nationaux chaque année de voter
des lois de finances votée mais n'ont
pas vu les l'impact évidente quand vous
posez la question un autre local s'est
débrouillé à dévier les dangers pousser
et qu'à la fin il parvient à sortir des
bilodeau et qui vous avez un ukrainien
où j'ai passé un exemple de bien
sahélien
un américain qui vient qui devient
djihadistes ou juifs ou dans ce bois là
où des facteurs ou des sherpas de
ce que vous voulez du kremlin si la
patte de la liquidité pour le ps ait
failli lui vend c'est comme ça qu'ils
voient des choses et je sais pas moi
[Musique]
assurer la sécurité de co2 n'est pas
évident le 6 décembre 2021 sept
combattants de la coordination des
mouvements de l'azawad était assassiné à
une attaque par des membres de l'état
islamique
qu'on gérait la protection de ces
mineurs les membres du csp conflit qu'il
envisage de généraliser une taxe
d'environ 5% surtout les gains de plus
d'un million de francs cfa soit 1500
euros par mois
mais le représentant du csp ignore
combien les groupes djihadistes prélève
dans les zones qu'ils contrôlent
[Musique]
ce qui est possible que les groupes
jihadistes dans les zones qu'ils
contrôlent les braqueurs ont des
influences font payer des taxes et c'est
souvent agnel
c'est une pratique musulmane ou quand
vous avez la fin de l'année une tête un
nombre de biens il ya un cas qui est
fait ici de la base de vos biens vous
payer un pourcentage
et les djihadistes ou autres ne sont pas
aussi des gens naïfs
se sont déjà qu'ils sont intelligents
comme nous tous
peut-être que chacun de nous peut avoir
un jugement sur pourquoi ils font tout
ça mais il est évident aussi les
contextes politiques les besoins
économiques des populations et ils
sabotent même dans les façons de d'être
contraignant ou d'imposer des règles qui
sont de temps en temps mais j'ai parce
que derrière tout ça les communes dans
tout ça il ya des dividendes
pas pour tous
c'est la logique d un peu développé
[Musique]
au mali mais aussi au niger au burkina
faso des groupes armés s'emparent et
tire profit depuis 2016 des sites
d'orpaillage dans des zones où l'état
est faible ou absents plus de 5
milliards d'euros sortirait tous les ans
de ces trois pays sous forme de lingots
d'or une hémorragie un manque à gagner
important pour les états producteurs
cette ruée vers l'or est aussi un
facteur d'insécurité pour les
populations
regardez cette carte du burkina faso en
noir les sites aurifères artisanaux en
rouge l'installation progressive des
groupes djihadistes ces trois dernières
années la corrélation est évidente
[Musique]
l'exploitation anarchique de l'or s'est
étendue à toute la région car les
frontières sont poreuses
des milliers de pistes permettent de
passer d'un pays à l'autre
beaucoup de trafiquants circulent à moto
sans jamais être inquiété
c'est ainsi que la déstabilisation
régionale du commerce de l'or s'étend
aux pays plus au sud direction tingréla
une petite bourgade ivoirienne à la
frontière malienne
lors de ce quart gold pourrait aussi
venir de côte d'ivoire
septième producteur d'or du continent
[Musique]
attingre et la lorette une source
importante de revenus
8 à 10 kg sortent toutes les semaines de
cette petite bourgade
la plupart des mines sont dans la
sous-préfecture de papara nous avons pu
avoir accès à l'une des rares mines
artisanales légal du nord du pays
ces mineurs se sont organisés en
coopératives
elle s'étend sur 25 hectares
les creuseurs viennent ici de toute la
région dès qu'il ya un trou qui donne
comme on dit des centaines de jeunes
affluent il raconte qu'avant la guerre
il travaille aux champs avec leurs
parents mais depuis dix ans les
activités de ces villages ont
radicalement changé
ayasse amazon
ça va donner
je m'appelle khalifa
je suis hors payeurs
c'est mon métier maintenant
c'est dieu en fait qui décident de ce
qu'on va trouver
nous on ne sait jamais si on va gagner
quelque chose
quand on descend dans le trou
l'ours paillage fait désormais partie de
l'économie de ces villages du nord de la
côte d'ivoire chacun prend sa part les
membres de la coopérative l'association
des jeunes l'association des femmes pour
ce militaire à la retraite qui gère
aujourd'hui la coopérative leur
contribuer au développement local
mais si c'était un peu dans le désordre
d'havas dans la clandestinité
c'est pas ça nous avons des le vélez
la coopérative bourgogne je vous dis
qu'à aider le collège de papara qui a
construit on a poussé la sent prêt de 20
millions pour construire une salle
numérique une cantine pour le collège là
pour une cantine scolaire pour l'école
primaire
on a trouvé du matériel sanitaire pour
l'hôpital
on a payé même une moto pour l'hôpital
pour faire leur petit déplacement à
servins il n'avait même pas dans villa
donc voilà que la pole position les
responsables de cette mine sont un peu
inquiet pour leur sécurité
il aimerait n'employer que des ivoiriens
pour éviter les infiltrations de
djihadistes mais la mobilité des
populations dans cette région est telle
que cet objectif est intenable
alors la mine est encadrée par les dozos
cette confrérie de chasseurs
traditionnels
soutiens les forces de l'ordre dans ces
villages reculés du nord du pays
tout le monde et fouillés à l'entrée
comme à la sortie de l'avion
[Musique]
ici c'est un mineur malien qui vient
d'être interceptés on lui demande de
montrer ses papiers
hier
à la salle 6 et 16 ans
nouveauté sur les i désormais ce qu'il
nous trouve un parent su produire que
will avec moi parce qu'il est mal et
vous dis que celui là mon tuteur s'il
n'a pas de tuteur la coopérative terres
le découvert la brigade doit plus un peu
revue
les membres de cette coopérative
explique il travaille aussi avec les
responsables des villages maliens et
burkinabè qui longe la frontière
car lors de tengrela a toutes les
chances d'être vendus hors de la côte
d'ivoire
la dynamique du secteur découle de
l'histoire de la région l'orpaillage au
nord du pays est liée à la guerre civile
et à l'occupation de ces zones par les
forces nouvelles les mouvements rebelles
qui ont porté alassane ouattara au
pouvoir en 2010
laura est exploité dans la région à la
faveur de la guerre pour ce consultant
qui a travaillé pour de nombreuses
organisations internationales
le trafic actuel s'inscrit dans la
continuité de l'histoire militaire de la
région
à l'époque de l'heure de la rébellion il
n'a fallu un moment donné nous rires oui
c'était des soldats mais par les soldats
de métier c'était des gens qu'on a
répliqué çà et là qui pouvait me pointer
les fautes alvin moment donné il fallait
la nourrit il fallait pays de
l'équipement il fallait si vive
et
gdiri bim ils ont trouvé
dix ans la source de financement quitter
l'exploitation aux hivers à tirana mais
ne pouvons pas dealé avec les bureaux
légaux d'achat d'or de vente et d'achat
d'or qui sont à abidjan dans la partie
gouvernementale
il a fallu se tourner vers d'autres
sources de financement dans les pays
limitrophes tels que le mali et
le burkina qu'une langue culture de
d'orpaillage et donc il y avait des
systèmes bien huilée qui était sur place
avec des acheteurs
[Musique]
les facteurs historiques ne suffisent
pas à expliquer pourquoi bamako s'est
imposé comme le principal centre d'achat
d'or des pays sahéliens les taxes à
l'exportation ils sont bien moins
importante que dans les pays voisins 3 %
et seulement sur les 50 premiers kg d'or
mais pas toujours regarder la facture de
sky gold elle montre clairement que ceux
qui ont transporté leur n'ont payé que
5000 francs cfa moins de 10 euros pour
toute la cargaison
à bamako la situation ne fait pas le
bonheur de tous les acteurs du secteur
dans la raffinerie kankou moussa l'une
des deux raffineries industriel de la
capitale malienne le patron est un peu
inquiet
cet homme d'affaires italo suisse qui
connaît le pays depuis plus de 20 ans
n'a pas pu réaliser son projet
il avait investi en 2014 plus de 6
millions d'euros dans cette usine qui
permet de fondre des lingots pur il
espérait récupérer l'essentiel de la
production malienne mais aussi de celles
des pays voisins
et
[Musique]
amis à 10%
si les fonderies du grand marché
fonctionne à plein régime
cette raffinerie ne reçoit pas
suffisamment de matière première pour
ces installations flambant neuf cette
société qui exporte en suisse ou aux
états unis intéresse très peu les
orpailleurs locaux personne ne veut se
plier aux régulations complexe des pays
occidentaux les affaires sont bien plus
faciles vers dubaï
[Musique]
nous avons demandé à dario s'il
connaissait la société sky gold et nous
lui avons montré la photo des lingots
ce1 à différents cas ratures qui est un
composant dehors des
dingos et un aussi des autres métaux
précieux mais qu'aucun argent à jean
blanc il contient plati dans certaines
cas elles contiennent les pleurs
palladio dubaï aux glissements v7 or en
cette forme parce que les raffineries
dubaï est vive et gagne sur les autres
métaux et sont gratuits
mais j'ai niveau 60 tonnes d'or par am
brutt par dubaï savez des 25 que système
d argent seulement free
parham
sacem économies
pour savoir d'où vient alors de sky gold
derrière nous conseille de parler à son
laborantins on nous explique qu'en
identifiant les métaux associés alors on
pourrait théoriquement avoir une idée de
l'origine des lingots mais que
l'exercice est complexe car il faudrait
avoir une base de données des
composantes géologique de toutes les
mines de toutes les régions du monde
dans cette raffinerie on sait pas
régulièrement pour les clients les
métaux précieux de l'or brut ans et au
mali on récupère surtout de l'argent
blanc moumouni déplorent les
exportations massives vers dubaï un
manque à gagner pour les industries des
pays africains
les prenions conscience de ce phénomène
et que nous créons de la valeur ajoutée
parce que quand nous parviennent à
transformer une matière et mary si les
clients qui voulons de leur viendra
investir dans des infarctus est ce que
je pense être affiné les faits en aura
beaucoup plus vert a tiré au mali cela
va créer beaucoup d'emplois pour les
jeunes fondement et que ne se privant
pas d'emploi est il ya beaucoup de juges
qui vient avec et ça va créer aussi de
là le produit
mais dario un autre projet qui lui tient
à coeur pour vendre de l'or parfaitement
traçable il envisage de construire des
centres de collecte et de services pour
les mineurs artisanaux 15 centres de ce
type aurait dû être mise en place en
2022 si la situation sécuritaire l'avait
permis
notre mission dans le pays ces deux
arrivées à voir entre sable
jusqu'à la pointe de regret
l'aîné mais caractéristique l'énorme
prénommé qu'il a produit une idée en
phase avec les recommandations des
organismes comme l' ocde en supervisant
la chaîne d'approvisionnement développe
les communautés minières et on réduit la
contribution de l'or au financement des
conflits c'est un scénario vertueux mais
la situation qui domine aujourd'hui dans
les zones minières est bien différente
et
[Musique]
en suisse
l'année passée en 2009 ils ont pris 24
tonnes d'or dubaï
l'origine n'est pas déclarée mais il
entre en suisse pour aller à les
différents raffinerie
mais 24 temps parce
qu'il aura en fait moi j'aime pas trop
dubaï mais comme raffinerie s'est nourri
de la hantise et non un futur come comme
il fallait sortir avec un homme celle
ci lors de ce cas gold avait pour
destination dubaï c'est par pure
commodité
il est parfaitement légal d'amener des
lingots dans ses valises et le transport
de l'or dans les bagages à main est
devenue l'une des meilleures méthodes
pour importer de l'or illégal aux
émirats arabes unis
[Musique]
surnommée la cité de l'or cette
mégalopole s'est imposé ces dernières
années comme une plaque tournante du
commerce international de l'or
les autorités ont fait du métal jaune un
pilier de leur économie mais aussi de
leur tourisme
étape incontournable pour les visiteurs
le principal souk de l'or est situé dans
le quartier historique de deraa
on trouve des lingots et des bijoux sous
toutes les formes et dans toutes les
couleurs on peut aussi facilement y
vendre son or
ici tout brille un même le safran en
provenance d'iran est servi dans des
récipients doré
lors de sky gold était destiné à dubaï à
la société par pia elle est située juste
en face de l'immeuble du centre de l'or
nous nous y rendons
au détour d'une rue de la vieille ville
- touristique par pia gold est toujours
en activité plusieurs fois sollicité ses
responsables ne nous ont jamais répondu
en procès en afrique du sud depuis la
sphère des 73 kg en janvier 2021 cette
société a par ailleurs été épinglé un an
plus tard exactement dans un autre
trafic de près de 50 kilos d'or cette
fois ci via les comores
elle achetait de l'or un autre société
immatriculée au mali mali métal le
schéma ressemble étrangement au
précédent des patients malgache qui
s'acheminait sur dubaï avec des factures
malienne
en 2018 les émirats arabes unis a
apporté 50 tonnes en provenance
d'afrique en 2020 le chiffre était de
500 tonnes en moins de cinq ans les
émirats ont multiplié par dix leurs
importations en provenance du continent
africain mais les consommateurs qui
viennent faire leurs emplettes au souk
de l'or se préoccupe peu de la
provenance
les vitrines affichent des lingots
suisse et les vendeurs explique que l'or
est simplement recyclés à dubaï
l'or est moins cher et si il y a
tellement de beauty c'est pour ça que
vous voyez tous ces gens venir acheter
de l'or à dubaï on importe de l'or de
suisse d'afrique du sud de grande
bretagne de leur pure et on fabrique ici
les bijoux
plus de 4000 sociétés travaillent dans
le secteur de l'or à dubaï la fiscalité
avantageuse car on ne paie ici ni impôt
sur les sociétés ni sur le revenu pour
sortir de la dépendance du pétrole et
devenir un hub commercial
les émirats arabes unis se sont dotés de
45 zone franche
[Musique]
le 10ème six centres d'affaires pour les
matières premières a été créé en 2002 68
tours sur 200 ha c'est la plus grande
zone franche des émirats
le secteur de l'or est l'une de ses
activités principales le deuxième 6 6
est doté d'organes pour le promouvoir
mais aussi pour le réguler le conflit
d'intérêt manifeste
malgré nos efforts au 10ème sic comme au
gouvernement
aucun officiel n'a accepté de nous
recevoir nous nous tournons alors vers
un chercheur suisse qui travaille depuis
plusieurs années pour démontrer que leur
salle des zones de conflit est blanchi à
dubaï
son rapport a été établi sur une
cinquantaine d'états africains les
contrôles sont extrêmement laxiste
si vous arrivez avec
votre ordre bagages à main vous devez
simplement se présenter un certificat
d'origine et une facture de certificats
d'origine va être même pas obligé de
montrer vous pouvez simplement payer une
amende et les gens dans le souk de l'or
me confier tous la même chose il ya
aucun problème à passer les douanes vous
pouvez très facilement falsifiés un
certificat d'origine vous avez
simplement également juste montrer votre
votre passeport c'est qu'aujourd'hui si
vous regardez les pays où il ya des
zones de conflit que ce soit la vie
démocratique du congo le burkina faso le
mali le niger le soudan lors de ces pays
finit toujours à dubaï d'une part
directement et d'autre part
indirectement si vous prenez l'ordre
pays démocratique du congo ça passe
généralement par l'ouganda où le rwanda
et ensuite ça finit à dubaï de même pour
l'or par exemple du nord du burkina faso
dans les zones de conflits ça passe
généralement par le mali avant d'être
exportée à dubaï donc de dubaï oui c'est
vraiment la machine à laver entre
guillemets de delors problématique
africains issus trop souvent des zones
de conflit il est difficile de connaître
le nombre précis de raffinerie à dubaï
mais une fois raffiné l'origine de l'or
est impossible à retracer physiquement
les raffineries ont donc une
responsabilité particulière dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement
certaines personnes me disaient non mais
qu'est ce que vous aller enquêter aux
émirats arabes unis s'est de toute façon
juste de l'or recyclé et le problème de
l'eau recyclée c'est que ça englobe tout
ça peut être de l'ordre nazi ça fait de
l'or ici
d'un trésor de 200 ans où ça peut être
de l'or qui étaient aux mains d'un d'une
mine d'un groupe dia liste est à peine
moins d'une semaine plusieurs rapports
dénonce le manque de mesures visant à
encadrer le commerce de l'or à dubaï un
rapport du groupe d'experts de l'onu
2019 déploré qu'aucune saisie n'était
faite sur l'or passé en contrebande en
2020 le gafi l'organisme
intergouvernemental contre le
blanchiment d'argent et le financement
du terrorisme
alertée dubaï sur les risques de
blanchiment d'argent en mars 2022 le
gafi place et les émirats arabes unis
sur leur liste grise
[Musique]
en afrique du sud le procès des passeurs
malgache continue la société sky gold
qui n'avait jamais répondu aux appels de
la justice sud-africaine a enfin donné
signe de vie au bout d'un an de
procédure
les responsables de par pia la société
de dubaï veulent absolument récupérer la
marchandise qu'ils ont acheté le
gouvernement de madagascar aimerait
aussi garder l'or mais personne n'a pu
prouver d'où viennent les lingots
[Musique]
l'histoire de cette fraude douanière qui
porte sur 3 millions d'euros n'est que
la partie immergée de l'iceberg
une goutte d'eau dans un commerce
international qui se chiffre en
milliards d'euros qui occupent les
polices du monde entier
et qui nourrit plus de 40 millions deux
mineurs artisanaux
avec les passeurs qui risquent à chaque
voyage quelques années de prison les
creuseurs sont souvent les seuls
appréhendé dans les cercles criminels de
l'afrique du sud au mali
ils sont les premiers maillons de ce
trafic mais ils continueront à alimenter
la chaîne d'approvisionnement à assouvir
la soif d'or de cinq continents
[Musique]
et voilà pour ce document signé caroline
dumay correspondante de france 24 en
afrique c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur france 5
[Musique]